[Musique]
les allemands n'ont plus que deux jours
pour faire leurs achats de noël et
déguster un vin chaud en extérieur car
dès mercredi tout sera fermée commerce
non essentiels écoles 1re confinement
plus strictes la scène se déroule dans
le 14e arrondissement de marseille
lorsque les policiers arrivent beaucoup
de participants sont aimés chez d'autres
se filme en train de fuir les forces de
l'ordre partout et puis quand j'ai perdu
le goût l'odorat je suis parti à la
clinique quand en me disant bon je vais
peut-être aller voir et là ça s'est
enchaîné très vite parce que quand j'ai
passé le scanner j'avais une
pneumopathie qui était assez grave
alors que je toussais pas je ne sais pas
j'avais très mal au dos je le
royaume-uni est le pays le plus touché
d'europe on rappelle parfois beaucoup
d'ennemis coronavirus l'exécutif vise la
vaccination plusieurs millions personnes
d'ici la fin du mois le premier ministre
boris johnson a été un des premiers à se
vacciner d'ailleurs pour l'exemple mais
vous le voyez effectivement les effets
secondaires ces deux soignants vacciner
et frais et des manifestants anti
vaccins ont donc défilé dans les rues de
la capitale britannique
pas plus tard qu'en septembre dernier
c'était le maire de londres sadik khan
qui publié tout fier de lui un sur ces
réseaux cette photo en train de se faire
vacciner contre la grippe il encouragé
les londoniens à faire la même chose
mais le problème c'est que cette photo a
produit l'effet complètement inverse
puisque des internautes se sont rendu
compte
et bien que le capuchon était toujours
présent sur les grilles vous allez le
voir sur cette photo qu'on a
zoom et je me suis vu mourir comme je
pense beaucoup de personnes et
malheureusement il y en a qu'un qui 15
cents morts mais j'avais demandé à donc
à voir
un peu d'affaires et puis un papier et
un stylo est ce qu'on nous reproche
alors ça va jusqu'aux plus grands
délires et ça peut aller jusqu'au
génocide
on nous dit que le seul ce vaccin va
être léger aussi de la même façon qu'on
l'avait dit plus on avait tué les
personnes âgées avec le rivotril dans
les maisons de retraite et puis on nous
rapproche aussi d'inventer un des cadres
pauli 2-2 de gauche et d act up au vide
pour avoir par intérêt économique
on est dans du délire comme protistes
négationnistes d'ici quelques heures les
premières doses du vaccin files heures
vont quitter cette usine du michigan
objectif vacciner dès demain des
américains je suis sûr à 100% que nous
allons acheminer en toute sécurité ce
vaccin dont nous avons besoin pour
vaincre l'ennemi covin ce vaccin de
pfizer aujourd'hui quelque 40 et si vous
faites vacciner vous ben moi oui
j'aimerais bien que vacciner surtout je
vous rappelle que nous sommes des
personnels de santé que nous ne sommes
pas dans les priorités le des vaccins
donc oui je pense que les personnels de
santé doit faire partie des priorités et
vaccinal en amérique il y a eu plus de
morts dus coronavirus qu'il n'ya eu de
morts pendant la deuxième guerre
mondiale
c'est ce qui ce qui se passe avec cette
maladie est gravissime donc ça mérite
que on conquiert la confiance des
français pour faire en sorte comme en
confiance on puisse aller vers la
vaccination pour soi mais surtout pour
les oréades et si en dernier ressort
le choix est entre eux restés confinés à
voir l'explosion des envies suicidaires
des étudiants l'ailé les petits
commerces les artisans et l'ensemble de
la population qui ne peut pas sortir
eh bien je dis que c'est en dernier
ressort et ben oui pourquoi pas la
vaccination en dernière on n'arrive pas
dessus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m